véronique sanson tu sort un nouvel album
c'est le neuvième ça s'appelle mois le
venin c'est ça est ce que tu as déjà
réfléchi à ce que tu allais dire quand
les télévisions au tulle être invité non
mais enfin tu vas me fournir l'occasion
je sais pas par exemple si je te dis tu
as une minute pour me le vendre mais ce
que je te dis qu'il est formidable qu'il
est bien et que j'ai mis longtemps à le
faire ce que vous pouvez dire que c'est
bien de chine en mai
je crois que la seule preuve que je le
sorte sinon je n'aurais jamais partout
c'était l'argument tu le vois stephen
stills encore wilson se posent tous les
fans bas bien sûr le père de mon fils et
je le vois oui - qu'est-ce qui fait en
ce moment même ce qu'est la o2 pour
malte on attend maintenant à bord ils
ont tout ça y est maintenant ils sont
tous ralliés à tourner ils sont plus en
meilleure forme que jamais je crois
qu'ils vont sortir un jeu c'est qu'ils
sortent un disque qui prendrait stills
nash and young a beau et parfait tu
quitteras de tout recommence toujours
comment ce qui est très très beau dire
mais quand tu seras plus âgées tu
continueras à te montrer où tu écriras
pour les autres pas vraiment je suis je
pas encore adam longtemps je sais pas
non peut-être pas souhaité faire appel
pour les autres ouais je crois devient
un des shows ou j'écrirai des livres de
cuisine c'est quelque chose qui fera des
liftings par exemple quand tu seras
pourquoi charles du frais et ça c'est
quelque chose que je ferais bien sûr je
reprenais à notre disposition des moyens
formidables pour retarder les les
le vieillissement et je consens
peut-être mieux dans sa peau
si on se demande si on est beau plutôt
que se sont dit oh là là je peux pas
aller on peut pas être beau être
complètement pas d'accord mais je peux
aussi on peut le faire il faut le faire
tu es cigale ou fourmi italie du pognon
de côté pendant les années fastes
je ne sais pas c'est pas moi qui m'en
occupe mais j'espère de tout coeur
je sais pas non je fais confiance à
quelqu'un à 5 sur 15 jours je vais lui
dire mélange m'arrête je me retire je
vais en grèce je vais en espagne un pool
de l'afrique
si le mec te dis on n'a pas à mes peux
pas me dire vous faites maintenant à moi
c'est impossible on est sûr entendu
parler des questions qu'ont les
questions qu'ont souvent ri
des pilotes l'avion un avion invisible
fameux avion invisible américain qui
transporte la bombe atomique
puis d'un seul coup tu es en l'air et
puis ne manche à balai ennemis ou tu
peux plus le diriger cet avion et tu vas
tu écrasé et a quand même le choix de
t'écraser soit sur new york soit sur
moscou où tu t'écrases aux questions
qu'on a très qu'on a laissé cinq ans
contre et je pouvais je peux pas dire au
mieux la règle en a c'est en ça que
c'est quoi oui c'est raconté jean tu
préfères trompait route à main sont
obligés de répondre à tes obligé de
répondre lecture moscou alors à bon bah
voilà une réponse poudre au hasard j'ai
major là toute façon si tu mourrais tu
préfères être incarné ans marguerite
duras ou en marilyn monroe
ouh ah bon ah oui tu préfères la beauté
que l'intelligence mais il n'y rien ne
prouve qu'elle est et qu'on imagine ton
mec tu te trompes d'un jeu qu'est ce que
tu fais tu lui perce les yeux à perceuse
électrique nuit le couple le sexe à la
tronçonneuse et ni l'un ni l'autre
qu'est ce tu fais je d'oise de mon
esprit
ouais je plus absolu c'est tout pas bien
méchant c'est un méchant je serai plus
gêné s'y trouvait au lit avec un autre
mec ou avec deux filles
[Rires]
oui c'est une vertu
je serai je serai très jeunes ici n'est
trouvé avec d'aussi bon moi je dirais je
trouve un colloque mais ce serait plus
normal
et toi c'était obligé de faire l'amour
obligé sous la sous la menace d'une arme
tu préfères et le faire avec une jolie
fille vrai qu'avec les carnets québec
ah bon oui ces défis 7e non ça passe
pour coucher avec ça m'intéresse pas
vraiment toujours dans la série amour
obligatoires tu es obligé qui préfèrent
faire l'amour avec bar giscard ou chirac
oui mon voyage dure question à baron
fait jamais bon d'être séparés j'ai
jusqu'à il est pas mal et chirac n'est
pas mal mais faut choisir je choisirais
tu es obligé de choisir
eh ben
ce quart alors ah bon ouais plaisir
alors imagine que tu adoptes des enfants
tu préféré adopter des jumeaux
cleptomane des jumelles pyromanes c'est
merveilleux ces questions oui c'est le
vent qui s'imposera pas et on attend
alors deux jumelles pyromane ou deux
jumeaux qu'elle tenait exactement
tu écoutes c'est plus rigolo les jumeaux
capte mal parce qu au moins ils
ramèneront des trucs de référence est-ce
que tu serais prêt à mourir pas prêtes à
mourir pour que y ait plus jamais de
chômeurs en france
non tu meurs tout de suite ah non non je
suis pas prête
pourquoi moi parce que c'est toi papa
tabouret pour capitale pourquoi tu es
prête à mourir par exemple ok plus
jamais une inondation bangladesh tes
pattes à mourir je suis pas prête et
chef je suis prête à mourir pour rien ne
vaut rien du tout non plus même si à
plus jamais de pauvres sur la terre
pendant des siècles conditions il faut
que ça aille très vite alors ce qui
dégoûte le plus c'est la scatophilie la
nécrophilie
alors la scatophilie c'est quoi ces gens
qui mangent des délais chose déboutant
et la nécro fils ait des gens qui
mangent des gens morts bon jeu des
cadavres c'est ce qui les excite si tu
le sais tu manges et l'état leur a alors
qu'est ce que tu écoutes le mois à la
micro fini au moi c'est de la viande
rouge la borne morte alors ah bon oui
nous allons messieurs réponse est bien
donc c'est la nécrophilie tu préfère
manger un cadavre que manger des
excréments
parce que si je mourais de frein présent
je mangerais bien un cadavre mais je
mange crois pas que je mangerai
des choses en dernière question con tu
pars sur un vaisseau spatial pour un
voyage qu'il a duré à peu près 4 50 voix
si l'on est que tu peux amener un seul
passage et enfin l'occurrence et une
passagère est ce que tu veux mais oui tu
préfères france gall ou catherine là à
moi je connais mieux catherine l'arabe
france gall je crois que j'aimerais
mieux catherine la retraite leur série
ce passé louis lalande a bon c'est trois
le risque de passer mais toi aussi je ne
dis pas attention à ce qu'on se marre
bien avec catherine je dis pas qu'on se
marre pas bien avec france je la connais
beaucoup moins bien donc c'est catherine
lara pendant quatre ans en quatre ans
avec un peut-être un mayer les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux